depuis quatre ans aussi rendu aux trois
quarts de nos cibles et dans les onze
ans à venir le canada va atteindre et
dépasser ses cibles là les cibles dont
parle justin trudeau
ce sont les cibles de l'accord de paix
mais est-ce que depuis quatre ans le
canada a vraiment réalisé les trois
quarts du chemin pour atteindre ses
cibles de réduction de gaz à effet serre
[Musique]
l'objectif de l'accord de paris et de
réduire d'ici 2030 les émissions de co2
de 30% par rapport à 2005
je n'ai trudeau laisse entendre que le
canada a déjà atteint les trois quarts
de cet objectif
à l'écouter on comprend que les
émissions de co2 au canada ont diminué
de 22 et demi pour st pourtant non
depuis 2005 les émissions de co2 n'ont
baissé que de 2 % au canada elles sont
passés de 730 mégatonnes à 716
mégatonnes en 2017 les dernières données
disponibles
quand les libéraux disent qu'ils ont
atteint les trois quarts de l'objectif
de paris ils font une projection des
effets vont avoir leur mesure
ce n'est pas encore réalisée c'est une
nuance très important et même si les
projections des libéraux se réalise pour
atteindre et dépasser les cibles de
paris il reste encore beaucoup de
travail à faire la production de pétrole
de gaz les transports bresc dans les
secteurs les plus polluants au pays
les émissions de co2 continuent
d'augmenter